et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
quel week-end prud'hommes députés et les
filles 3e circonscription de gironde 1
florian philippot président dp tribot
des patriotes et enfin françois pupponi
député modem 8e circonscription du val
d'oise bonsoir à tous les trois
messieurs merci d'être en direct sur rt
france on l'a entendu thierry breton
très sûr de lui un qui affirme ne pas
avoir besoin du spoutnik v cette
déclaration elle vous a surprise choqué
florian philippon fait de l'idéologie
politique sur les vaccins ou c'est d'un
tout autre ordre
honnêtement il ne m'a pas surprise
puisqu'on sait que l'union européenne
depuis des années et hystériquement
engagé dans une croisade contre la
russie en fait la demande d'ailleurs des
intérêts américains
c'était une très mauvaise chose pour la
politique française je pense qu'il
aurait intérêt à un dialogue constructif
avec la russie du point de vue des
intérêts français
mais ça on est donc le cédant tout le
même donc y compris dans ce domaine là
donc voilà ils font là il faut que la
politique est ce que tu devrais ce que
ce qu'ils sont que la france devant
retirait que les français devraient
exiger leur gouvernance et que la france
devrait s'occuper elle même de ses
affaires parce que l'union européenne
est en véritable fiasco sur cette
affaire du coc vide le vaccin mais enfin
déjà avant c'était au tout début
d'épidémie elle qui nous avait demandé
laissé grand ouvert nos frontières c'est
elle qui a acheté du raimeux désir pour
un milliard d'euros en octobre alors
qu'on savait que ça servait à rien voir
c'était dangereux donc tout ça il
faudrait une enquête d'ailleurs un peu
sérieuse
voilà et donc l'union européenne c'est
le seul point positif de cette crise
c'est que je pense qu'il ya pas mal de
français maintenant qu'ils se rendent
compte qu'il vaut mieux être un pays
indépendant et souverain et qu'il faut
leurs écrits quitter cette structure au
plus vite alors loïc nomme c'est vrai
comme le précise ici le spoutnik v est
utilisé dans plein de pays à l'argentine
le mexique plusieurs pays d'orient la
slovaquie et la hongrie a même qui
s'affranchissent des règles de l'europe
vladimir poutine on l'a entendu qui
s'interroge sur les entreprises
pharmaceutiques les lobbys les intérêts
quel est votre avis sur cette question
est ce qu'on est en train de faire la
politique du lobbying on ne défend pas
spécialement les intérêts des citoyens
européens sont cette affaire clairement
la question se pose quand l'on voit
effectivement le fiasco de la stratégie
d'approvisionnement en vaccins de
l'union européenne et et les paroles de
thierry breton on voit qu'il aurait été
bien inspiré d'avoir un petit peu de
modestie et puis de sado s'occuper
vraiment de l'intérêt sanitaire des
populations avant toute chose parce que
la question aussi c'est sur ces labos
pharmaceutiques ayant effectivement on
peut vraiment se poser la question s'ils
défendent pas plutôt ses intérêts là
c'est que il faut rappeler aussi que
tous ces vaccins aujourd'hui que
monsieur thierry breton semble défendre
ceux qui sont produits par les labos
pharmaceutiques notamment américains et
ou autres c'est qu'ils ont été mis sur
orbite par une manne financière
importante de nos pays de l'union
européenne mis en orbite mis sur orbite
par la recherche publique qui les a
lancés qui a permis d'aboutir dans les
recherches mais mis sur orbite aussi par
des financements publics pour commencer
à les produire et en fait ces vaccins
que l'on n'a même pas on les a déjà payé
une fois et il faudrait les payer une
deuxième fois alors que on en manque et
qui on serait bien inspiré d'aller
regarder effectivement comment on peut
disposer d'autres sources de production
et comment aujourd'hui on peut aborder
cette question on ne peut plus l'aborder
sans parler de la question des licences
libres puisque aujourd'hui 50% des
capacités de production mondiale de
vaccins ne sont pas utilisés du fait de
discours comme celui de monsieur breton
on a besoin on a besoin de personne
d'autre on se débrouille très bien
on n'a pas besoin des autres et
aujourd'hui on voit qu'en plus le vaccin
est très mal répartis au niveau mondial
alors que c'est une pandémie mondiale
les pays riches on dispose un petit peu
les pays pauvres pas du tout et donc
c'est aussi cette question là qui est
posée par cette polémique entre la
russie et l'union européenne déclenchée
par des propos à mon sens irresponsable
de monsieur breton a peut-être qu'un
gala merkel est en train de réaliser
qu'elle s'est fait un peu avoir sur ce
coup là parce qu'elle semble pas être
vraiment d'accord avec
le commissaire européen je vous propose
d'écouter la chancelière allemande
en ce qui concerne le vaccin russe je
suis d'avis que tout vaccin autorisé par
l'agencé européenne du médicament
devrait être utilisée dans l'union
européenne
je préfèrerais une commande de l'union
européenne mais si celle ci
n'intervenait pas alors l'allemagne
devrait agir pour elle même et c'est ce
que nous ferions françois pupponi
c'était étonnant cette déclaration d'un
gala merkel si proulx européenne
collective comme elle l'a montré dès le
début ça dit quoi
non mais quand l'europe fait une erreur
mais les pays reprenne un peu leur
pouvoir vert la déclaration du
commissaire breton est absurde on a
besoin de tous les vaccins et si un
vaccin qui s'appelle boutique v qui est
efficace et qu'on peut obtenir il faut
le faire on voit bien qu'on a du mal à
vacciner massivement la population en
france
astrazeneca à des difficultés de
livraison
s'il ya une solution alternative il faut
surtout pas s'en priver sincèrement je
pense que la déclaration n'était pas
celle qu'il fallait est ce que
l'allemagne qui est aussi confrontée à
une reprise de du virus actuellement
c'est très bien qu'il faut accélérer la
vaccination et que si un moment l'europe
se bloque parce qu'elle veut faire de la
diplomatie vaccinale ce qui serait
absurde il faudra passer outre et
trouver des vaccins là où il y en a dès
lors qu'ils sont efficaces
alors on verra bien ce que diront les
spécialistes européens le 10 avril à
moscou
mais si effectivement le vaccin et et
valises et et bien il faudra en acheter
massivement pour accélérer le processus
de vaccination dans notre pays un
florian philippot je m'entretenais tout
simplement avec des jeunes à dubaï qui
m'expliquait 1 28 et 25 ans tu qu'ils
avaient reçu leur deuxième dose de
biotech aide ses soeurs sont même la
demande et on les appelle tout
simplement
voilà c'est source sûre puisque les ai
eus en ligne moi même on peut comprendre
peut-être l'agacement d'une angela
merkel qui voit sur son tarmac allemand
décoller des avions remplis de bio and
take me rappelle que c'est un chercheur
d'origine turque un migrant qui était en
allemagne qui a trouvé ce vaccin
l'europe fès s'est fait avoir
l'europe est dans la main des lobbies de
toutes façons on des puissances
financières sur tous les sujets c'est
vrai pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
c'est vrai dans beaucoup de domaines son
histoire c'est cela c'est de plus en
plus la scène un pouvoir qui n'est pas
élu pas démocratique responsables devant
personne donc ça conduit naturellement à
ce genre de dérive puisque moi je suis
pour la vraie liberté vaccinale je pense
qu'une stratégie sanitaire ça peut pas
être qu'un vaccin d'ailleurs on voit que
l'union européenne aussi
enfin vers ans et macro sont bien
d'accord avec ça bloque les traitements
h r block la prévention pas cher etc etc
il impose même l'austérité à l'hôpital
ce qui nous a mis dans une situation
très compliquée mais ce moment de livres
on a fermé 110 millions 25 ans en france
une en plein l'ayant demandé à de
nombreuses reprises donc si vous voulez
moi je suis pas surpris ce que dit
madame merkel sait que l
quand il ya un souci elle sait qu' il ya
un pays qu'elle a un pays qui s'appelle
l'allemagne et qu' il y avait tout ce
qui s'appelle l'intérêt national
en france ça n'est pas possible d'avoir
ce discours en france les tellement dans
la religion européiste qu' on ne met
jamais l'intérêt national avant tout
jamais on est capable de dire à la
france va reprendre sa souveraineté et
faire telle ou telle chose
jamais jamais vous l'entendez macron
dire cela jamais absolument jamais été
alors que l'allemagne évidemment ne voit
l'europe qui à travers les intérêts
allemands germanique bien compris et je
ne lui en veux pas je pense que c'est
tout à fait normal si j'en veux aux
dirigeants français ne jamais défendre
nos intérêts et nous enfermer lancer de
prison est un fiasco dans la main des
lobbys des conflits d'intérêts de la
corruption et de l'inefficacité est ce
que vous parlez de la france florian
philippot c'est vrai que la france les
vaccins arrivent au compte gouttes ont
fait un petit état des lieux tout de
suite regardé sur
cet écran qui va apparaître donc les
livraisons les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes father prévu 9 millions reçu
5 6 millions moderne a prévu 1.5
millions reçu 600 milles astrazeneca
prévu 6 millions 1,6 million comment
vous à l'elysée ces chiffres loïc
prud'hommes c'est retards intempestifs
en france c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure en fait c'est que la
politique européenne elle et elle est
vraiment enfermé dans une logique
libérale mais qu'ils n'arrivent même pas
à maîtriser puisqu'ils se sont mis dans
la même contrats opaques croyants sur
parole des laboratoires qui n'ont de
cesse que de faire des profits sur sur
notre dos donc ça ne fonctionne pas et
on le voit ici puisque les promesses ne
sont pas tenues l'argent et bien
contractualiser mais on ne verra pas le
début du bout d'une seringue gaydamak
sont donc c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure maintenant il ça suffit cette
affaire ça suffit il y à 50% des
capacités de production mondiales qui
sont inutilisés je vous rappelle
notamment que dans cette affaire de
spoutnik et il ya un contrat qui va être
passée avec l'inde propose pour produire
400 millions de doses de sportive et
c'est de ça dont il faut que l'on parle
maintenant c'est mettons tous ces
vaccins en licence libre
mais toutes les capacités de production
mondiale pour faire face aux besoins que
nous avons sur l'échelle de la planète
parce que cette pandémie on ne s'en
tirera pas et madame merkel ferait bien
de s'en souvenir on ne s'en tirera pas
en jouant perso dans son coin et en
essayant de ramener des doses vers soi
parce que tout ça circule aujourd'hui
dans sur la planète et que c'est
ensemble et c'est donc avec une
stratégie vaccinale mondiale c'est ce
qu'ils appellent l' oms de ses voeux
c'est ce que st plus d'une centaine de
pays ont demandé c'est là que la france
aussi a voté contre et peut-être qu'elle
était inspiré par thierry breton sur la
levée des brevets pour qu'on puisse
produire partout sur la planète et qu'on
puisse fournir tous les gens qui en ont
besoin
y compris ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de payer des sommes faramineuses aux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
effectivement tout ça sent le conflit
d'intérêts
ap l'année c'est vraiment déplorable que
nos stratégies vaccinales que la santé
de nos concitoyens et concitoyennes ne
soit juste juste jouer à la roulette
russe d'une d'un capitalisme hyper
financiarisé qui ne sait pas aujourd'hui
faire face à la pandémie
avant de vous faire réagir françois
pupponi on va regarder à l'échelle
européenne maintenant un astrazeneca
lance tankan plus accablants comme comme
constat je vous laisse regarder les
chiffres 1 100 millions commandés au
premier trimestre 30 millions livrer 300
millions commandés au premier semestre
100 millions livret est ce qu'il ne faut
pas revoir la liste tout simplement des
producteurs tout simplement renégocier
les contrats si c'est possible en tout
cas l'exigé je crois qu'il faut déjà
sanctionné ceux qui ne respectent pas
les contrats c'est le cas d'astrazeneca
la responsable européenne la dette
depuis la coulisse on l'a dit il ya un
près de respect des contrats il faut qui
éventuellement des sanctions s'ils ne le
font pas et si on s'aperçoit
qu'astrazeneca comme les autres ne sont
pas en capacité de respecter les
engagements
il faut aller chercher des vaccins
ailleurs et le spoutnik comme un à
l'autre il ya le vaccin doit également
il ne faut pas hésiter à le faire la
situation est trop grave
on voit bien fait je rappelle que si on
veut une immunité collective en france
il faut qu'on soit sur environ 500000
vaccin jour loin loin loin du compte et
donc on voit très bien qu'il faut la
stratégique était celle de l'europe
aujourd'hui patauge un peu et patine un
peu compte tenu de l'absence de
livraison en fonction des contrats qui
ont été passés il faut donc trouver des
vaccins ailleurs ce que dira tous les
jours astrazeneca s'est pas bien ce que
vous faites on vous sanctionnez on peut
le comprendre mais ça ne fait pas venir
plus de vaccins
donc il faut trouver de l'extérieur et
sincèrement le spoutnik v comme d'autres
vaccins peuvent être une solution
complémentaire
et puis il ya les pays que qui sont
capables d'acheter les vaccins
et puis à ceux qui ne sont pas capables
d'acheter vaccins qui n'ont pas les
moyens qu'il faudra aussi aider donc il
faut augmenter la production de vaccins
de l'autre dans le monde et ça c'est
indispensable urgent parce que sinon
nous n'arriverons jamais à la limite et
collective qui est indispensable pour
enrayer la pandémie
florian philippot tout le monde le sait
ce qui en plus de vaccins c'est ceux
aussi qui ont payé plus cher en israël
les états unis et ce qu'il aurait fallu
avoir ce pragmatisme à l'échelle
européenne bahdja sont là bas l'union
européenne n'a pas donné d'informations
très précises puisque vous savez que
tous ces contrats ont été négociés dans
une opacité toulan table à tel point que
même nos ministres sont à peine au
courant voire temps au courant de ce qui
a été négocié à tous à être faits
lamentables et l'union européenne dit je
j'économise l'argent des contribuables
face à elle n'a pas empêché de faire un
chèque d'un milliard d'euros pour
acheter je le disais du rem désir au
mois d'octobre au moment où l'om est
baptisé déjà que se servent à rien donc
si vous voulez tout ça est un argument
ambulants aux mangas je pense que ça
sent beaucoup plus effectivement conflit
d'intérêt
et puis je voudrais quand même dire que
derrière tout ça il ya le refus de
réfléchir sur un traitement qui est
aussi un énorme problème est lui en
pleine rue un rôle fondamental dans
cette affaire en refusant des choses sur
les lieux avec thil et c'est alors que
beaucoup d'études
le magazine capital a recensé 40 études
internes alors alors en devises est
comme entrer l'efficacité de ce
traitement qui coûte que 8 euros et mon
avis c'est son problème c'est qu'il ne
pleut que huit ans et puis l'union
européenne et est aussi depuis ce 17
mars la déposer une initiative
législative européenne en ce sens
elle nous embarque vers son passeport
sanitaires et ça moi je ne veux pas et
j'ai pas envie que ce soit une structure
supranationale qui décide à la place du
peuple souverain
une rupture quand même pour nos libertés
pour l'égalité entre les citoyens
avec cet affreux passeport sanitaire oui
il ya plein de raisons de se défier de
l'union européenne et d'entamer un grand
débat national sur le fait de s qu'on
doit à imiter des anglais et sortir de
ce machin avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
loïc prud'hommes pour revenir déjà sur
vos propos la france clairement intérêt
aujourd'hui à déclencher sa procédure
d'urgence au sein de l'union européenne
pour acheter de son propre chef d'autres
vaccins que ceux commandé par l'union
européenne ce que menace de faire
finalement l'allemagne angela merkel je
ne suis pas pour qu'on s'aligne sur les
positions
lippert égoïste et libérale de
l'allemagne moi ce que je vous dis c'est
que la france devrait plutôt jouer de
son influence pour demander la levée des
brevets pour que effectivement on puisse
produire en nombre
à tout le moins pour l'union européenne
pour déjà pour commencer mais ça c'est
une évidence mais on peut pas en quoi la
jouer perso je me permets de vous couper
parce que l'allemagne quand même comme
je vous le disais productrice a trouvé
le vaccin
vas-y s'il avait été égoïste peut-être
qu'ils auraient pu le garder pour eux
nous on n'a pas trouvé le vaccin les
français mais ça c'est encore une autre
question c'est comment on arrive à ce
fiasco dans la recherche française où on
n'est pas fichu de trouver ni un vaccin
ni traitement ni même de réouvrir en
l'espace d'un an les milliers de lits
qui aujourd'hui nous nous font défaut et
font que nos proches et nos anciens sont
en train de de passer de vie à trépas
pour des défauts de stratégie sanitaire
dans notre pays c'est quand même assez
hallucinant en 2021 et moi ça me met
très en colère mais c'est pas la
position de la france pour moi la
position de la france serait
effectivement de pouvoir participer à ce
que c'est le vaccin soit produit en
grand nombre sur le territoire national
bien évidemment si on si on avait fait
ce que l'on réclame depuis des mois la
france est soumise réquisitionner les
moyens de production nationaux pour
produire des vaccins mais pour cela il
faut lever les brevets il faut que tout
ça soit d'un domaine public qui est
aujourd'hui nécessaire
l'allemagne ne réglera pas ses problèmes
seul pas plus qu israël pas plus que
ceux qui ont les moyens de se payer
j'allais dire en premium des des vaccins
alors que les autres n'en n'ont pas et
vont continuer à diffuser la pandémie
mais tout ça est éteint et en tout on ne
peut pas effectivement centre est la
question que sur les vaccins mais c'est
celle de la production de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française qui a montré à
quel point pour verser des dividendes
notamment sanofi a laissé à laisser
passer toute recherche sur des remèdes
ou sur des vaccins mais qui espère bien
en tirer les fruits financier pendant
que nous on en meurt donc tout ça est
absolument insupportable aujourd'hui et
je pense qu'on serait bien inspiré de
reprendre la place qui est la nôtre dans
le concert mondial en exigeant que enfin
le bien commun soient défendues françois
pupponi sur ce débat de lever des
brevets sur les mecs sains je pense
qu'avant la france n'aura pas le choix
comme des autres pays européens
fait toute la stratégie français c'est
de dire on évite le confinement au
maximum mais on va vacciner et on savait
très bien que c'était le mois d'avril
qui devait être le moment où la
vaccination elle est rentrée en plein
régime
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on
a vacciné d'abord les personnes âgées
puis les personnes à risque que c'est
compliqué et qu' on est loin de
l'immunité collective
donc il faut vraiment qu un moment au
mois d'avril on soit capable de passer à
un niveau de vaccination important mais
si nous n'avons pas les doses la
question se posera si un moment où
constate que l'europe n'est pas capable
de nous livrer les doses parce que les
fabricants de vaccins ne sont pas
capables de livrer l'europe
alors oui toute façon vous savez
l'allemagne commence à le faire d'autres
pays comme la hongrie l'on fait déjà et
ils tous les pays européens se posant la
question si roman l'europe est
défaillante chacun reprendra son droit
essaiera de sauver sa propre population
c'est sûrement la pire des solutions
mais on pourra pas reprocher à un
gouvernement français de dire devant le
constat d'échec pour nous obliger de
prendre des décisions et moi va jouer là
des cibles à la déclaration de djeha
merkel aujourd'hui est très révélatrice
en disant voilà on laisse encore un peu
de chance à l'europe de pouvoir régler
la situation si l on n'est pas capables
chacun reprendra sa liberté d'action
comme le veut le droit aux pinces d'or
ce domaine la fin florian philippot
le mot de la fin moi je trouve que quand
dire que l'on va sauver son peuple c'est
la pire des solutions sur ça bizarre ce
que vient de dire monsieur plus petit
non ça s'appelle prendre ses
responsabilités un gouvernement français
est là pour défendre les intérêts
français
d'ailleurs c'est ça que ça nous
paraissent incroyables alors que ces cas
de tous les pays du monde et tout le
monde c'est comme ça ce qui n'empêche
pas les coopérations internationales qui
doivent être les plus fructueuses et
amicale possible enfin bon le boulet en
gants quand même le président de la
république française devrait se souvenir
qu'il est quand même en charge des
intérêts français plutôt que de rêver
d'europe en permanence et de produire
donc ici les cauchemars voilà c'est tout
moi je ne pense qu'il faut quitter cette
structure est qu'il faut avoir
l'honnêteté d'avoir le ce débat devant
les français à internet
merci à tous les 3 loïc peu d'âme
florian philippot et françois pupponi
d'avoir été avec mon direct sur rt
france